pamper appears to take aim at uh Trump
for looking backwards and claiming
victimhood calls for serious leaders
right okay so that's what Pompeo just
said guess what Pompeo wants to do he
also wants wants to run what is not
attractive is the victimhood didn't work
for Hillary it doesn't work for anybody
in business it doesn't work it's just
not attractive period when you take that
doesn't work for anybody because it's
not a good look yeah there's another
giveaway when you call Elon Musk a
[ __ ] artist or you make these
unnecessary enemies look at you made
this point eloquently uh with uh
Blagojevich and Kerry Lake when she went
after the CNN reported she said she's
more DeSantis than she is trumpian I
don't know the way the way she carries
herself and speaks I think that's a
really key point that you can still go
out I'd love to have a one-hour sit-down
one-on-one with uh Donald Trump and just
ask him a set of questions I think it'd
be a very fair interview I would want to
ask him certain set of questions that no
one's asked them there's a certain set
of questions that no one has yet asked
them it's not a gotcha question it's not
any of that stuff it's you know it's
it's certain set of questions that I
have for for the guy but you know going
back to what you're saying uh some
people are saying well is he gonna go
back to that uh yes he is yeah so so
what do you think is that like a
negative thing he can go back to that
all day long make people laugh be
sarcastic do what he does and what he's
been like for 76 years or 77 years what
is not going to be a turn on is
victimhood mentality well and I know
Adam wants to make a point here you said
also during the Blagojevich that there's
a reason the Obama uh Bruce Springsteen
podcast didn't take off because Obama
isn't a podcast host that's not his game
right why do you think he was such a
powerful president and so respected
because he's not a podcast host right
people don't want a podcast host for a
president people don't want somebody as
outlandish and bombastic in reality
television and I disagree okay I
disagree no those are two different
things uh those are two different things
because what people don't want to hear
like with a Obama and a uh Bruce
Springsteen Obama became a victim as
well what are you talking about you you
people don't like that Obama's entire Mo
was look they're doing this because I'm
black that's not attractive either I
mean I'm not sitting here taking one
side or another I'm not attracted by
victimhood mentality no matter who does
it okay no matter who does it I don't
care if I ever get into it my like the
other day we want to do The Tick Tock
video right to show it the only thing I
want to show with the tick tock video is
to say look what they did right after
the China clip and see what happened do
you know still me wanting to make that
video is uncomfortable detail on the
side because a part of it is kind of
like well you're acting like a victim
all of us tend to go there sometimes
well man I've been working so hard
lately you chose to be a seal let me
tell you all this pressure just stop
bitching about you had kids nobody told
you to have unprotected sex let me tell
you you know how life is being a single
man you chose to become single nothing
is attractive about victimhood mentality
it's got nothing to do with Left Right
middle Center black white asian Middle
Eastern women men gay straight no one
cares stop being a victim it's not
attractive if he goes there I don't care
I'm personally not going to resonate to
that I as a man I'm not turned on by
victims if a person next to me complains
too much about white people are after
him or her when people would call and
say the following
I caught one of our guys the other day
for closeout
So today we're having a we're watching a
fight in the backyard you know what his
first 20 minutes I'm on the side I'm
having to call you wise Paterson for the
hooker fight yeah Tom Collins so what
happened close oh let me tell you man
you know the bamboo was given issues
I said are you again going back to so
you're the only person that a technology
you should last night
I'm just naturally not attracted to
victimhood mentality I'm not so if he
goes there you're gonna see what happens
at the podcast here and what what the
feedback we're going to be given we're
not going to endorse victim with
mentality listen the moment you choose
to get into politics what has politics
been known forever dirty uh what else is
it man they're gonna Target you it's
dirty they're gonna come after your
family
what then don't do it yeah you signed up
you signed up for this shitty job
there's nothing about this job that's
attractive if somebody wants to go into
politics they came after my family
that's what they do that's what critics
do their job is to come after your
family then don't go play sports LeBron
if you don't like what Stephen A says
then don't go run for office Trump if
you don't like what people say then
don't go be a media guy Obama if you
don't like what they say about you but
whatever you do don't act like a victim
it is never attractive ever attractive
in any industry is not to be honest he
should just not bring up any of the
election [ __ ] just focus well to be
honest and I it's weird for me to say I
miss the entertaining Trump because
right now for the past two years it's
Joe Biden shaking hands with people that
aren't there sniffing people's hair it's
just been a [ __ ] show I do I'm not gonna
front I miss the like what the hell is
he gonna say next I agree with you 100
if he just does not bring up the
election type [ __ ] yes I I would like
the you know what we're gonna hold fauci
accountable we're gonna go after the doj
because of their their bias and what
they're doing and now Tyler showed me a
clip from uh Christopher Ray the FBI
director where they ask him in front of
Congress they said can you tell us right
now if there was for January 6th was
there any FBI agents dressed as Trump
supporters inside the capital before the
doors were open you know what he said I
can't talk about it he's like the
congressman was like wait you can't say
no you guys didn't have anybody inside
waiting As Trump supporters and then
opening doors for these people so I want
I want talk crap but I want
accountability and I do like all the
stuff that you said that he talked about
about the Fentanyl and the securing the
you know securing the board and all that
stuff I want that type of stuff I don't
want to go I feel bad for myself that
you know I watched it as a Critic and I
watched it as a voter like I try to I
asked Kobe one time how do you watch
movies he says I watch movies and I just
listen to the music he said I watch
movies and I turn off the audio just to
see how they're acting then I watch the
movie I'm like what he watches movies
like that so I watch it as a voter and I
watched it as a you know a Critic right
as a voter I'm like okay that policy I'm
interested in that policy I'm also
interested in you're going to execute on
those policies I'm interested in those
policies being executed so that part
resonated with me as a voter not as the
personality okay as a Critic I give you
my feedback as a Critic you know how we
felt you know family not being all this
other stuff but as a voter I'm like okay
if he keeps talking those policies I
think he's going to have momentum order
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
[Music]